[MUSIC PLAYING]
[DONG]
[CHIMES]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
We talk about this all time.
The urge to create is like
a knot in your stomach.
When you finally
output something,
when you have functional
aesthetic output, when
you create something
artful in the world,
all of a sudden that
anxiety is gone.
All of a sudden that knot
in your stomach dissipates.
Right?
Instead you enter a modality
of cognitive ecstasy.
You enter an
exhilarating neuro-storm,
as we were talking about.
An intense,
intellectual pleasure.
A dopamine rush, a feeling of
you've made a contribution.
And that's what Shots of
Awe is to all of us here.
To you holding the
camera, you know.
To Jordan, to Barry,
helping to produce.
To Tom, you know, the crew
of people that get together
to ban as we try to like
literally go out of our minds
in order to use our
minds for the first time.
You know, to scramble with
self, to transcend the ego,
to see what's up, to
put it all out there
to transcend the
specific and only talk
about the universe for a second.
Leave the trick at the door.
Right?
That's what we're doing.
That's what Shots of Awe is.
To share our ecstasy,
to share subjectivity,
to break through the
screen, to do what we always
hoped technology would help us
do, which is to come together.
Warp space and time
and [MMPH] connect.
That's what we want to do.
[MUSIC PLAYING]